ich sage das ist auf jeden fall mega
mega geiles kisten versteckt na ja meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die folge
gefallen zu gewittern
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft facts mit euren fake sie
mir wie immer an kontrasten gmail.com
sein könnte ich würde sagen wir können
direkt anfangen uns war der erste fällt
mir zugesendet von petra sie meint dass
wenn ich zum beispiel hier einen hund
habe und der hund gehört mir und zwar
dieser genau jetzt mir deswegen hab ich
das an coolen knochen und ich habe zum
beispiel das schwein hier an schieße
erst mal gehe ich kurz der eine macht
diese begrenzung kaputt damit ihr seht
dass da keine inneren konflikte zwischen
den beiden sind hier die könnten
miteinander spielen die beiden die sind
wunder wundervoll werde bei dem
wunderschönen drauf ins all und der hund
liebt mich halt und wenn ich das
scheinen anschließe dann geht der hund
nicht auf diese schweinen drauf das ist
relativ komisch weil wenn ich das
schwein schlage geht der und direkt
drauf und tötet ist also des falls nicht
wegen mir das war wegen dem hund ich
kann ich das noch mal ganz kurz
demonstrieren
ich nehme mir hier ein schweinchen so
ich lass das jetzt mal hin schieße das
an und es passiert nichts mit dem und
ich kann das normale anschließt nicht
was ich vielleicht jetzt auch schon
direkt tot
danach stehen to business lebt noch wie
ich das jetzt allerdings anschlage kommt
der hund direkt an und tötet es also
dass dort jeden fall interessanter
effekt dass ihre tiere nicht anschließen
können wenn der hund töten soll oder
wenn ihr zum beispiel ein tier nur an
hinten wollt dann geht der spieler halt
geht der hund hat auch nicht darauf aus
ich konnte es nicht an spielern testen
weil das hier nicht im multiplayer ist
das könnt ihr nämlich einfach mal
irgendwie weiß nicht wenn ihren server
habe mit einem freund oder irgendwie so
ob das bei spielern auch so ich denke
bei spielern ist es auch so dass wenn
man die nur schlägt dass der hund dann
drauf gehen und ich wenn man die
abschießt also das perfekte mainz über
auf jeden fall sehr cool effect nummer
zwei ist auch recht interessant online
exporte sich im 140 verpiss dich
jetzt fällt wieder kaputt so dass wir
wieder und zwar ist es sehr interessant
dass diese ganzen rails also ich kann
mir die jetzt jede mal einzeln hier
nehmen
jetzt wird sortiert unten ich stehe so
eigentlich wenn ich also spiel und ich
möchte es machen kommt zack zack zack
ihr wissen besser bescheid sei wenn ich
allerdings nur so viel der lenkten sich
die ganzen rails immer in richtung f0
und f1 f2 die beiden gegenüberliegenden
also nord und süd heißt ich kann auch so
stehen also was ist sodann gehe nina
geradeaus so gehen die nämlich auch in
diese richtung nicht allerdings eine
andere daran platziere dann gehen die in
die richtung wo ich die rakete ag tätig
das weil es hier so ein komisches ist
dann gehen wir immer in die richtung wo
ich die quasi dran platziere also dann
irgendwie mal hier um die kurve und so
was also wenn ich die einzelnen gehen
die immer so wenn ich ein anderes
anpacke so und das ist halt auch
irgendwie interessant finde ich dass sie
sich alle so dem norden und süden eignen
das sieht nicht nur in dieser welt auch
in anderen welten probiert in drei
verschiedenen welten
es ist immer richtung norden und süden
dass die rails immer richtung norden und
süden gehen wenn man die einzeln hinlegt
wenn man die dann allerdings verbindet
dann ergehen die ihnen eine andere
richtung effekt ist sehr sehr kurz und
zwar wird der mir von quirin zugesendet
der erst mal schön in die mail
geschrieben hat haye kommt kräftig auf
zwei für dich erst wenn man sich in der
tür stellt kann man auch verstehen
das fand ich sehr witzig und zwar wenn
wir hier ganz einfach eine tür haben wir
machen diese tür auf und stellen uns
hier quasi so in den rahmen machen die
töne und zu dann sind wir in der tür
drin also ihr seht dass hier wenn ich
mich so angucke ich bin in der tür drin
und wenn ich jetzt einfach hoch springen
bin ich auf der tür so in dem rahmen
drin wenn ich noch mal hoch springen bin
ich auf der tür drauf also das ist noch
richtig simpler trick vielleicht
irgendwelche adventure maps oder so oder
wenn man irgendwie aufs haus drauf
kommen möchte da keine ahnung antrieb zu
zack zack zack zack da ist man oben
braucht also erinnert mich ein bisschen
diese trap platten wo man auch so drauf
springen kann was man drauf bringen dann
muss man klicken damit man hoch kommen
aber dass auf jeden fall auch cool und
quirin ich denke einige kannten das noch
nicht jetzt ein sehr sehr cool effect
von jan
sonst war möchte ich mich ganz ganz toll
bei dir bedanken weil es eine super
beschreibung bei hat mir sogar zwei
screenshots geschickt und den effekt
kennt dich kann ich echt noch gar nicht
dass es überhaupt funktioniert also soll
es recht sein dass das mega gut von
jannis und zwar ist es eine sehr sehr
geile sache ich brauche euch das mal
ganz kurz hier nach ihr setzt hier
blöcke hin also drei da und dann nochmal
drei so darüber dass ihr quasi das wiso
zwei balken habt dann können wir jetzt
einfach hier
zwei treppen hinsetzen oder ich mache
jetzt mal hier anders spiegelverkehrt
und jetzt müsst ihr eine treppe setzen
diese um die ecke geht also die da so
gegen steht wird also wie sofort kann
man ja so machen dass man hier so macht
und dann macht man so und so hat man
sowieso nicht dass das so ist sondern
das hast du abgerundet ist ein holz so
will ich keine haben aber gut
normalerweise wenn ich jetzt hier zum
beispiel eine kiste hinter stelle oder
hier so ein doppel kiste kann ich hier
ja nicht durchgreifen das ist ja auch
wenn ich jetzt mal weg machen zum
beispiel eine hinstelle kann ich ja auch
nicht dadurch greifen obwohl ich hier
auf einer höhe wenn ihr ich muss ja ich
kann hier nicht durchgreifen ich muss
immer hierhin greifen wenn ich
allerdings diese ecke hier nehme
geschäfte macht da rein
wenn ich jetzt allerdings hier an der
ecke sonne kiste anvisiere kann ich
diese kiste öffnen ihr seht dass da die
schließlich noch und auf dieser seite
hier auch also nicht durch dieses ding
durch weil dann ist es wieder so ein
blog sondern nur nicht passieren
dadurch kann ich die kiste öffnen durch
dieses ding durch dieses kleine loch
allerdings geht es hier halt nicht
obwohl hier die gleiche entfernung ist
es liegt halt irgendwie daran dass
dieser blog hat ihnen wieder gegen
geneigt ist aber irgendwie auch nicht
also dieser dieses ding hier ist nur
kind eine textur und keine masse also
ich kann dadurch greifen das ist wieso
die leni sich also das ist ein sehr sehr
cool effect finde ich sehr interessant
wenn man so kisten verstecken will
einfach so kann man dadurch greifen
hätte ich das mal ein hero gemacht mache
ich dann wahrscheinlich in dem neuen
projekt will und sonst würd ich sagen
das ist auf jeden fall mega mega geiles
kisten versteckt
na ja meine lieben freunde wenn euch die
folge gefallen sogar zu gewittern
wenn euch defekts folge gefallen hat
dann lass doch einfach eine bewertung
darüber will ich mich auf jeden fall
sehr sehr freuen wenn die mir ein
kontrast gmail.com schreiben und sonst
würd ich sagen ich hab ne nachricht
bekommen wir sehen beim erst mal wieder
rein machst gut ich kann euch noch das
geheimnisvolle geräusche starken und
zwar das letzte geräusch wurde erkannt
von racker 1999 ich habe mich diese
kaugummi dose geöffnet dass sie war das
geräusch da hat er recht gehabt jetzt
geräusch hier hat sich das define
geräusch erwartet für ein geräusch wie
macht man mal
was ist das für ein geräusch meine
lieben freunde schreibt wendy kommentare
wenn er richtig liegt ist in der
nächsten folge oder neben den anderen
folge wer das auflösen müssen schüler
viel zu langer zeit und ich würde sagen
ich habe die macht und